hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Eve now things are
starting to get pretty interesting here
I mean we've kind of taken a trip into
hell Kevin you know the eyeballs and I
just wouldn't read does this loan I have
a congestion problem uh I don't know
that's a strange thing to say a painting
of a girl painting him some larger ice
painting of a white snake or a sperm
painting of some scenery okay perfect oh
goodness oh my oh my oh crap I screwed
it up didn't I ah I'm not going the
right way am i oh I'm not going the
right way
ah there there there crap asks stachy
mushrooms eyes I goofed I done goof goof
try again maybe okay good I need to get
to there which means I need to go over
there and push that over there and then
go over there and then push that over
there as simple as that so if I push
this up push this over
no that wouldn't work at all yes it
would then
yeah I work right yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's something on the chair taint
eyedrops tah-dah sorry I'm actually
using my brain for once it's very hard
it hurts a little bit never done it
before so everyone back up it's all
inside my brain explodes all over the
webcam I apologize in advance
hello yeah the flowers are nice give me
that flower there I'll let you through
oh I just wanna have a smear no just
want it for a little bit yeah all right
I know that would have killed me I know
it would and because I'm so curious to
see how it'll kill me I'm gonna give it
the rose because I'm curious I know
it'll kill me but I'm gonna do it anyway
uh no oh you go all right here you now
hold on Eve are you sure about this
yeah I'm sure so pretty okay
well fine then why didn't you give him
your rose Gary if that is your real name
if you really are just someone from the
gallery okay so I gotta use the eye drop
stare back oh that's creepy Oh what are
you doing Oh use eye drops there you go
feel but I'll look in it it's so cute
kinda not really not all that cute
actually I give it staring intensely at
the wall
all right then why
ah here we go well now something on the
ground red glass ball oh thank you
seriously that I was like downright cute
oh maybe I there's a can I've to place
here yeah there we go okay
aha I could have good now I've just
pulled that painting off the wall behind
the big tree you mean back in the Apple
area talking about that area are you
talking about in here
oh no I'm guessing I'm oh wait labyrinth
oh okay there's trick solving mazes hug
the right hand side and you'll reach
eventually not a bad trick but that
doesn't help the ceiling being far too
low for comfort not to mention those
weird things loitering around be careful
not to get trapped between them okay
okay
that doesn't sound healthy oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no directly south from
the red paint there's two spots of red
paint
felice tiles from which red paint yeah
hey no no no no no no I like mazes not
very much oh maybe this one huh yeah
fruits on the wall present yeah baby
yeah buddy
oh crap l would that do where that do
that do what it do what did it do did it
uh no what did it do what did it do
um excuse me pardon me pardon me
hug the right inside something about
that said hug the right hand side no I'm
confused cuz something happened or at
least it's sad that something happened
then nothing happened or did it oh wait
duh this door wasn't here below
okay I know a lot of you go okay I like
this place very much I know a lot of you
brought yelling at you computer screens
cuz I make people do that a lot doesn't
look like very comfortable sitting well
Gary why don't you make it rose glass
couch melancholy more like melon holy
[ __ ] it's disgusting hahaha puzzle
more like so puzzle why anyone made it
huh huh okay those real bones feeling
more like I'm feeling like these were
made of ass yeah yeah alright that'll be
pretty clever something about buying the
tree silver ring wedding ring oh I know
the wedding the the the the the bride
and groom I need to put it on the left
hand because that's where it's supposed
to go for weddings I think maybe maybe
not
I'm pretty sure it goes on the left hand
yeah on the ring finger right yeah look
at her hey I didn't catch it but that's
okay I got a bouquet it made me want a
bouquet lady thank you you look so happy
but now what all flowers that the guy
wanted flowers ah he wanted flowers I
give the blue painting flowers and then
he'll choke on them and die it's exactly
what I want to happen
gibble k oh it smells nice
that was good thanks so much as promised
you can go through just take this door
in we'll see you okay goodbye
alright unbalanced box heart and custody
I feel like I'm going through this game
oh my
I am shocked at this games ability to
constantly give me the creeps no matter
what what room I go in I get the creeps
a lot a whole line uh
wait well no no no I saw something
something happened I saw something okay
maybe it's just amazed that it was
talking about over there hugged the
right side I don't know lady hmm
locked headless tan she hit list and I
show that the creepy crawly what was
that why was that hello lady a lady in
red are you gonna okay oh I got a bad
feeling about this area oh I got a bad
feeling this is one of the paintings in
the gallery okay hey he's got something
I always face does not look good oh do
okay didn't need to see that I'm uh six
two nine five all right
I think that's what it is yeah yeah sick
tu-95 yep okay all right good for me
let's uh go now way oh yeah huh
I guess bad feelings I got all sorts of
bad feelings how many paintings a
woman's are there in this room I don't
know I didn't I didn't
one pull 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 then what
about the one that moved
izes 11 12 13 there's 13 paintings
including the one that's mobile I'm
assuming you wanted to count that one no
not that was it 12 oh come on it's got
to be one of those it's nah
oh I know yeah the password with six two
nine five okay good
okay painting depicts of what happened
to her to crash why did I do that we
know there's a spot on the ground where
there should be a Vaz table I know I
know how to do this
okay what did that do what did that do
oh okay he's just a [ __ ] how about you
no wait no no no no that wasn't there
earlier but there's there's painting
ladies ladies painting this I don't know
what do they want me does that mean
there are now 11 11 total paintings
because one wasn't really a painting I
don't know a mere or oh look at that
he's really tall you son of a [ __ ] you
back off you [ __ ] a mannequin head when
did this get into the room a bouche what
am I supposed to do oh he can bead
uh-huh give me the heebie jeebies you we
know this is a choice table Gary now
don't do it right Eve now my those
immature of me well let's go yeah Gary
that would have been horrible error okay
would it have been I meant here now okay
so if that one's down that means there's
actually 11 paintings maybe I don't know
I don't know that's still lacked I
didn't get anything from the painting
room why did I go in
no no no no no 11 - dingus
ah come on 10 are there 10 now huh ah no
there's so many of them there's so many
of them
no know what to do 1 2 1 2 3 4 oh ah god
damn it stop that huh uh-uh
I need to heal like a lot large bookcase
he moved to the left oh no no no that's
I need to block cuz oh no no no no no
something's gonna come in something
gonna break in I picked up familiar man
and woman who pleased wah oh my mom and
dad you do resemble you a bit EEB why
would such a painting be down here where
are they well I can't say that I know
either they must be somewhere I thought
she was a tough kid but this is even
getting to her
why wouldn't he get to a little kid
course if you're tired why not rest
you'll never be heard again well that
seems like a lovely idea I'm not gonna
do that
oh well you kidding me the door was wide
open
Oh oh crap what's happening
hi my god I knew it was a mistake I knew
it was a horrible error I know it was a
hard blow would've come in any way I
guess oh it was a horrible error
Oh what am I gonna do Oh what am I gonna
do how do I go out the hole of gaming oh
oh oh no oh no this has gone horribly
wrong oh oh no oh no good golly oh no oh
no this is very bad very bad
oh this is bad ah no oh let me save no
there's something new
oh damn it was I supposed to do there I
was just running around with no boy
ffice I was gonna die no matter what all
right I can get through this okay I
gotta get the unlock and then I gotta go
home
ouuuuu skittery little lady got dingus
get out of a rule get out of a wool no
no you come here come here come on come
on I'm gonna get you
Ernie he's so scary
oh hi no thank you I need to say that no
Jeezy's you stopped coming out of the
walls and stuff okay well this time
gonna push it to the right move to the
right
vamos stick thanks Gary you're the best
you're so great my parents yeah it's
cool and all okay now get here and then
survive the apocalypse is the only
requirement from now on I should have
been worried because all of the
paintings were coming off the walls
trying to kill me I should have known
that something was going awfully wrong
okay okay Hey
AM [ __ ] doll ride gonna tweet freebies
aw crap no no no wrong way wrong way
wrong way wrong way Oh wrong way wait a
minute what's that no wait no there's
only one painting left on the wall no
there's two paintings left on the wall I
got dingus no I can't go that way either
Who am I supposed to do that doors open
I didn't say that oh oh no oh yeah oh hi
I'm not moving
oh hi
what happened Gary yeah that should be
far enough I think we certainly showed
them hey that's my line
my well then let's keep go oh my what is
it are you okay Pheebs stay with me now
eep-eep
pretty sure I'm pronouncing it correctly
it's not if I don't think I really hope
it's not here but it's if that's bad
hello hi how's it going okay
oh no no no oh hi
thank you where am I now
oh no oh no oh no am i dead did I die
Oh what Oh
morning EEB how are you feeling I had a
nightmare I see you poor thing I can't
say I'm surprised
being exposed to such frightful sights
you know I guess it's good you woke up
I'm sorry I didn't notice earlier da da
da da would you like would you take a
look in the pocket of that coat he's a
candy you can have that feel free to eat
it let's rest here a while longer before
we set out again there are my hero Gary
I think of the code untitled rules of
the art gallery no loud conversation
photography food to drink no touching
the display no fountain pens no leaving
ever I was in that a little extreme uh
okay actually this is a good plate to
start it out dad this is good place to
stop it not started so anyway this is
getting I I like this
I'm sorry uh this is like when I was
playing which is else I really regret
putting it off for so long because this
is fantastic it really is so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
I like [ __ ] it
Oh buried line the blood
ha
come on time